E  T BODIEGNOFWEM INMO AEAG
UAI
RE T?
UE TO GAIN ITH
CONTROL OF RSIAN F SLOWER THAN O
WEEKSS
TR TO DIG INE POSITIONS AFTEEI
OLD DEFENSIVE LINEL
TO
, KHARKIV,CONTINUES TO COME UNR
BOMBARDMENT.
IS THERE WAS A RUS
AREA.T AN
ITS-30SURFAC-A
MISSILES NORMALL
DOCRT  INCOMING
MISSALYSTS BELIEVEHESE OESE MISE
PERHS NS MUNITTHLEA  FREOL
CO RAIR FO TACTIONFI ANK YOUO .
UNCOD 0 RI S.
>> THEKING THIS A ERROR.EYG THP
OF THEAR AR A WHAT'S DISTURBING
HUN O THISBUTHERE'S ALSO A VERYL
TALL R, DO YOU ULIOBUT IT'SIO R
THAT TERRY EVEN
TO GED  FROM WESTEN  CAN AN ITY
RECAPTUREDIFICANT TURN
RALY BIS IS ONE OF THOSE CHANGEE
S ARE E AS T THIS IS THEY AREIN
HARD NOT ONLY TO
T
THEY'RE ALSO TG E THEI
RT TST
BEE OF T WNG
BE RESUPTHE WEST AFINITE NEEPOM
RIGHPUTIBA THE ,  T
CHEMICAL OR NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
KEUKRAINE
BATTLEFIELD, VLADIMIR N RASSED
INTO ADE
U WOULIFE ISCHEMICR TACTICAL NAR
WEAPONS.
>> DON'T
DOOULD CHAE R
UN
>>O DESPERATEN, AS ISED AS HE
LING, THAT
THAT HE WOD BER FREDRICKA, AND R
THNEEDT BY THEES INTO A CORNER F
SAME TOKEN, WEEED TOAWARE
N INTELLIGENCE
DOINGARNSOVEAR LY FOLLOW WHAT
WEAPONS REASIN
NTRET  EMPLOYED AGRA
SOIND ENM PPONVERY QCK
VE
RECENTLY INDIANAN KNOWEY DON'T
THEVERYTNGNG,
LOOKTHEASTVING
INDIAHI
WOD ONLY
ME H
ONALLY
SIDERING THOSE
>> WELL, I THINKS E WOULD BE AN
LY BE AGCHEMIC OR TACT S INS SI
NDS  ISSUES
ATHEARTH FOR
THEIR KNOW,
ST THINK THAT, YOU KNON MAY ENT
DISSUADE HIM FROM DOING
JUST SHOWED  IT VERY C IPRN THE
G SOING LIKENDHIS KIND OF AN UL
SIGNALS THAT HE SRTHAT'STO>>KR
NEED AND THE USEARTHE U.S.YOU K
UNCED
NDL 00THL  U.S. HAGIVETHY TOOR1
BEGAN.
N THIS W THAT OF COURSE IS THE
OUINK WE NEENDERSTAND AT IN SERN
WA
THEY PROVIDI DEFENSE
S IN O TO
PREVENTILAR FORCES
RYAIR IN ERN EUROPE AND CENTRAL
AN ENR
OUR OWN SECURITY.